testosterone
is the male hormone that makes you a man
okay if you don't have healthy levels
and you're estrogen dominant
you're going to take on feminized
features it's why you see
here let me pull it up real quick see if
i can throw it up on the screen here
these guys you know the soy face usually
with the light beard
with the mouth open
[Laughter]
[Music]
you see this too much you know these
these days
um it's it's problematic these guys have
low t
there was a um there was a a test done
who are these three guys
uh if i can dig it up
and these guys had um
t levels of like 80 year old men and
they were in their 20s
what was that test it was like one of
these
you know um vice
guys if somebody knows what it is put in
the chat
uh i can't find it right now but if you
saw the picture of them
they were the they were the epitome of
the soyboy look you know the
you know the big wide mouth and the
crappy you know patchy beard
and like no chisel to their face and
like just bad facial features
you can also hear it in their voice when
they talk
um one of the defining features of
healthy testosterone levels is a deep
masculine tone to the voice i remember
my grandad had a great voice
um yeah that's it try guys on vice maybe
that was it
thanks for that let me look that up real
quick so i can show this to you
the vice dude guys hang on
struggle struggle to obtain medical no
complete a relationship
i'm gonna have to try to find it some
other time somebody can find it and just
put in the chat that would be helpful
um but all of these symptoms are
obvious i mean i can tell when i talk to
somebody on the phone i can't
i don't have to see their face if it's a
guy if it's like a guy named jeff and
i'm talking to him
and he sounds like a jennifer or
somewhere between a jeff and a jennifer
i know the dude's got low t
and it shouldn't happen um it's
it's it's just a combination of all
those things and it's really really
important
i mean um one of the other problems that
ends up happening
is infertility right so if you're
a guy i mean the whole point of being on
the planet is to scatter seed
and you're not healthy and you don't
have good sperm count you're not
in a in a position to attract the
opposite
to accomplish what you know you're
basically put here
but let me go here uh add the stream
here you go
so you got optimal and low t an optimal
you got sharp mind you have clarity of
thinking one of the things that a lot of
people don't understand is
when you've got healthy levels of
testosterone and your endocrine systems
firing on on all cylinders
um brain fog is uh
very very low like it's very limited it
does it doesn't get in the way you've
got strong confidence
you're of course always happy
happy-go-lucky you've got increased
muscle math
strong erections and libido functions
heart health i mean the heart's a muscle
one of the biggest uh misconceptions of
a lot of guys today when they hesitate
to look at things like testosterone
replacement therapy
is um they end up looking at it and they
go oh well that's bad for your heart
because there's like one study done and
there's like a guy that's 80 that had a
heart attack
when he was on trt but you don't see
guys in their 20s
having heart attacks they don't have
cardiovascular issues because they've
got healthy testosterone levels
it's important for heart health because
again it's a muscle to have that
you can have plenty of energy strong
bones so one of the things that happens
um that that you notice when you go on
trt and you start resuming a healthy
level of testosterone
is your bone density improves uh it
usually takes about six
to ten months or so but your but your
bone mineral density improves you
actually have healthier stronger bones
that are less prone to breaking when
you've got strong testosterone levels
low t you look like this guy you know
you're shaped like a pear
low energy increased fat tissue you know
breast tissue
up here uh increased risk of ed and low
libido increased risk of osteoporosis
which is bone issues
you're depressed one of the um big
problems that that guys suffer with
today
is they'll end up complaining to their
doctor that they're low energy their
mood sucks they don't feel good
you know they're 35 36 37 years old
something like that
and they feel depressed and then what
does a doctor do they put them on
ssris they put them on antidepressants
wrong move
you got the wrong doctor okay these guys
are in the business of prescribing crap
that ain't good for you
um you're probably showing symptoms
of low or lower testosterone than what
you had years ago
and a trt regiment would probably solve
that so all of these things are
stuff that you've got to consider
you